this is sky news welcome to our show
dedicated to interviewing people who
have something to say about the world
today and how it's changing they'll be
through politics sport business
entertainment public life or there'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times i'll be putting my
questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening the country is changing its
prime minister but should we also be
preparing to look ahead to change the
government kirstama is determined that
no matter who leads the tories their
grip on power will be short as the
temperature rose across the country
kierstama was watching and waiting to
see if the damage to the tory reputation
will be enough to propel him into power
at the next election
but who is he does he have the dynamism
and sense of purpose the job needs is he
even a little boring
also ahead vicky patterson was a reality
tv star famed for her time on geordie
shore and crowned queen of the jungle
but after the cameras stop rolling
there's a darker more serious battle at
play her new documentary addresses her
father's alcoholism and her own issues
with drinking she tells us her story
and music is changing the days of cds
and record stores have largely been
replaced by streaming services judge
jules has seen the evolution of the
industry a radio one veteran he's also
an entertainment lawyer i spoke to him
about the future of music copyright
cases and a live scene biting back after
kovid
after the 2019 general election the
labour party needed a leader to regain
the support of the nation
sarkir stama was trusted with that role
but winning back the voters has proved a
challenge perhaps until now so what do
we know about the man himself and after
more than a decade out of power can
labour really get back to the heart of
government i met him to find out
kirsten thank you uh for joining me on
the show today and and here we are in
camden the roundhouse your constituency
now
it's sometimes said that being the
leader of the opposition is the hardest
job in politics
but you're looking quite relaxed today
and it's not just your jeans it's not
just you dressed down thursdays
and we're in camden we're in your home
patch um but you you're looking pretty
relaxed you seem pretty relaxed at pmq's
this week is that because of the tory
leadership race
i think a combination really obviously
having gone through a really hard few
years in the labour party it is very
nice to be seeing the conservative party
tearing itself apart and providing me
with such brilliant material to attack
them but there's a slightly
wider feeling
of well being the labour party at the
moment because after
two hard years
of leadership we've got ourselves with
the local elections
and the wakefield by-election into a
position where
what
we had back then was
a hope yeah that we might win the next
election that's turned into a belief
yeah that we'll win that next election
and that i think has built a
sort of confidence and inner confidence
in life
that wasn't there until it's almost it's
almost when you took over everyone
you're the guy that's going to get the
party ready you're going to lose the
next general election and then there'll
be someone that succeeds you that gets
to bpm and you were going to do the hard
graft someone else was going to enjoy
the spoils yeah do you almost believe
now do you agree with that that you kind
of might have thought that yourself a
bit well when i took over two years
and two or three months ago
most people said
good luck here yeah um and then behind
my back but not nasty they sort of said
but you're never going to do it in one
term you can't get the labour party from
where it landed in 2019 worst election
results since 1935 etcetera
um to win an election did you sort of
think that today no i come on i never
did actually didn't you i knew what we
had the audacity of hope to change and
continue to change the party which we've
been you know working so hard on needed
to expose the tourists what they were
unfit to govern and then say well if not
then then why are i never thought we
couldn't do it but this year you can
feel it people are thinking you know
what
there's a belief now that we can is it
also because um
you found boris johnson's going and you
found him quite difficult you did find
him a difficult opponent right he was
kind of like stardust and
you found it hard did you to tackle him
it wasn't so much hard i
i really
disliked the fact that
he was prime minister of the country he
had
such an opportunity to do good things to
make the change that we needed and he
wasn't doing any of it
that that's those sort of empty promises
never delivering slogans but nothing
behind them that really frustrated me
and that that's not just a party
political point by the hat there are
conservative leaders theresa may as
someone i worked with when i was directs
public institutions she was home
secretary now i may have disagreed with
her politically but she had a sense of
what the job was the change you needed
to bring about and he didn't happen so
to this prime minister not pull the
levers and make the changes who would
you rather face across the dispatch box
leaving party issues aside which of
those two people does the national
interest required to be a leader i
really don't know i really don't know
who do you think would be better for the
country
i don't think either of them because
i think it's a mistake to think that
the change that we need now is just a
change at the top of the tory party
we've had 10 years
of stagnation and try to think
what are most people most famous what's
their emotion and i think most people
say i'm worse off i'm cutting back and
this has been going on a very very long
time and and so the ch they can't bring
about the change that we need in the
country also just just before i go on
are you also more relaxed because the
durham case is over you were exonerated
how did that feel for you the moment
that the police announced that
investigation was it a mouth go dry
moment for you you knew you must have
known in that moment
god i'm gonna have to resign if they
find me
was it horrible it must have been awful
it was a really big moment when they
made their decision
um i was confident we hadn't broken
how did it make you feel you must have
been nervous frightened did you think
god it's all about to go wrong for me i
was i really hated it uh if i'm honest
that being subject to a criminal
investigation
when you've been the director of public
prosecutions i hated it
um and you know i'm not like other
people in many respects who may say well
um that it doesn't really matter i did
you know it was re it really meant a lot
to me it was a burden
um that i was carrying i'm trying not to
show it of course
um but it was you know it was there
every day and of course i was
massively pleased when the decision came
through completely exonerated what did
you say to vic your wife when it
happened what does she say to you a lot
of people
when i took the decision criticized me
for taking two or three days to take the
decisions you may remember i do remember
said they were investigated and it
wasn't until the monday i didn't
remember
because
i put my whole career on the line
everything i've ever done i've been a
lawyer i've worked in northern ireland
i've been director of public
prosecutions i've been an mp leader
label party and i put all of that on the
line and i wasn't going to do that until
i'd sat down as i did on that sunday and
talked it through with vic my wife
because there's a huge decision to take
i took it as a matter of principle
because i thought strongly that those
who make the rules can't break the rules
i also wanted to show that not all
politicians are the same um because i
think that is very corrosive and the
delay was my fault it wasn't that people
have blamed me or the team and said why
didn't you get out quicker why did you
make the nine o'clock but but i i knew i
wanted i need to sit down on my own with
it with vic and say
this is what i'm gonna do
you know what do you think about it is
it the right decision i am literally
putting everything on the line
for a principle that i believe in but
it's going to have a huge impact on us
and that's what the sunday was all about
she didn't think twice
i mean you must have known on friday
that's what you're going to have to do
but you what you're saying is you had to
check it with her yeah i was up in the
northwest of the country when that
decision came through i got the train
back that afternoon and i knew in my gut
what i was going to do
vic knew what i was going to do
and she supported me through it
you answered you're still not cutting
through and
labour are doing well in the opinion
polls
but you're doing quite badly in terms of
personal ratings what what's going on do
you think well look
we need to put this in its perspective i
think in a proper context
um we picked up the labour party two
years ago having lost a very very badly
in the election
and nobody thought we could win the next
election
now the challenge i'm getting is why
aren't you further ahead in the polls
people need to remember that two years
ago they're saying to me you're not even
going to get into that position here so
yeah yeah one of the technical people
gains and ignore them and then
you know when i reflect on the two years
what are the things i need to do better
and differently one of them is to try
and blank out some of the noise some of
the time and just keep focused on the
job in hand members of the public and
this is a poll on june 13th jail
partners that members of the public
think you are
boring bland and dull
it's not very easy for me to say that to
you because it feels a bit rude but
that's what i mean does that hurt you
when
and you said ah no i'm not i mean what
what's happening that
who you are doesn't seem to connect
or are you a bit boring i don't know
i don't think i am i don't think you
think i am beth but
um
i'm not going to pretend that i think
that politics is a branch of the
entertainment business it's not running
the country is a really serious
issue and you need serious politicians
to do it one of the frustrations the
last
12 years is that we haven't had a
serious strategy for
growing our economy taking the
opportunities of the future i think we
need that what i like is when we get out
we go around the country talk to people
where they are whatever they're doing
great interactions whether it's people
communities businesses etc and i often
say to them what what do you want from a
government what's the thing that you
want most and none of them say to me oh
we need a bit more entertainment we need
it we need a few one-liners they say i
want someone serious who understands my
life is showbiz in a way
in a way he was showbiz and he was
hugely successful
so i mean in a telegenic age maybe you
do need a bit of entertainment in
politics i don't know was he hugely
successful well i mean he was
electorally successful he won an
election and i i'm
and that was very successful he got an
80-seat majority
two years and what seven months out
after that he is
um removed from office by his own side
in disgrace i mean if you take david
cameron or
theresa may
they left office but because of big
policy disagreements he's left office in
disgrace i don't think that's a success
two two and a half years or so
since an election
win you're kicked out of office because
nobody trusted
that's not my definition let me put it
let me put it another way to you because
i'm not asking you to be kind of
provocative i'm actually asking you
because it seems to be a barrier in your
ability
to win people over i mean do you think
there's something you need to change
about yourself or do you think it's more
that you need to stop being a lawyer and
start being a bit more of a politician
and what i mean by that is you seem to
weigh all your words so carefully when
you're on camera at the dispatch box and
is it because you're worried about
messing up that words count in a court
of law in a way they don't perhaps count
as much in normal conversation well i
think you know words matter and i do
think quite carefully about what i say
and um but actually when we're out of
the formal setting
we have all sorts of conversations in
lots of different ways you know do i
need to change the way i'm that we all
need to um change the way we are all of
the time but in the end what matters to
me is you know do you believe in
the mission of an incoming labour
government and the answer is yes do i
know what i need to do yes i do and
um how do i
i mean i came into politics um later
than most people so i'm learning no no
outside of politics
um in almost every other walk of life
there's always going to be challenges um
and whether you're an individual whether
in an organization within business you
you identify with the promise and you
fix it and that's my mindset what about
another reason the public might feel
unsure about you
is that they can't decide what you
believe and the reason i say that is you
spent years trying to get jeremy corbyn
into government now you seem to
completely repudiate the left you
acknowledge that's difficult for the
public that you were trying to get this
guy into power
and now you're kind of disowning
everything it was about in 2019 in that
general election did you want to see a
corbyn led government with every fiber
of your being
i wanted labour government of course i
did i wanted a labor government but my
focus is on the next election
people the reason i'm asking is that
members of the public might look at and
go hang on this guy was happy to have
jeremy corbyn as the leader he wasn't
worried about nashville then you do your
big thing on nato it's like what's he
about he's he's flip-flopping i'm about
me i'm about what i need to be
the prime minister i want to be of our
country and the change we've done in
labor party has been profound dealing
with anti-semitism making absolutely
clear that national security matters
that our support for nato is unshakable
building a new relationship with
business so one issue it struck me
over the strikes the rmt strikes
it was watching labour politicians tie
themselves in knots about did labour
back the strikes or didn't they back the
strikes what on earth was going on why
did you not take a clear position
well the position i took um was clear
and it was very very straightforward
which is
i didn't want the strikes to go ahead
yeah
that is the position that actually many
of those who were striking or likely to
strike wanted that want it resolved yes
um to say of course i understand the
frustrations of those who've had wages
that have not gone up in many cases for
a long time got a cost of living crisis
but what i wanted was the government
would say we do or don't support the
strikes you can say i don't want the
strikes to happen
but when they are happening the question
was does the labour party support the
rmt going onto the picket line or
doesn't it and it's a really simple
question and i just watched labour
politicians tie themselves in not
because presumably you didn't want to
upset the unions but you also knew that
the public were upset about the strikes
is that what was going on one of the
problems we've had in the labor party
for a long time now
is that
we envisaged ourselves as in opposition
the whole time we have to get in the
mindset of being in government if you're
in government this was what i said to my
shadow cabinet when we had the
discussion about the stripes if you're
in government and you're around the
cabinet table then you have to resolve
these issues you have to make sure that
the negotiations complete successfully
mark drakeford in wales did that he
brought the people together the parties
together and resolved the issue that's
the role of government
before we stop i've got to ask you this
because we're at the roundhouse in
camden now lots of people might not know
this
you're quite a talented musician aren't
you uh well i was
what's the best gig you've ever been to
in the roundhouse
you're thinking i haven't been
through oh orange juice i mean my
all-time favorite band played here
i don't i don't know orange juice
yeah uh two or three weeks we're
obviously coldplay you're going to see
my wife's absolute favorite now
so you coldplay adele
the other thing that people might
not know about you some things they
might not know you play football with
your friends once a week you take your
boy to arsenal matches and my girl now
well yeah and you get and when you when
your daughter was younger you used to
pick her up from school
and you used to organise your diary
around i don't think people might not
know that about you but this job your
job is totally encompassing you it can
destroy your marriage it can destroy
your life it can take over
did you ever harbor any ambiguity about
wanting to do this job
because of the impact on your family and
your family life that's the hardest bit
is the impact it has
um on my family it's the bit i worry
about the most it's why we never name
our children in public
it's why vic my wife doesn't do
interviews because
i want to protect them as best i can
because you know of course i'm in the
public eye that's the nature of the job
but it does take a toll on them we do
have some rules you know i'd try to
ensure that every friday by six o'clock
i'm home and i'm just there for vic and
the kids what did you do did you put
your phone in the bin or something well
put it in a job
but we do we get a takeaway on a friday
we have a family often fixed dad will
come over sometimes we'll do friday
night prayers with him um but um we then
argue about whether we're gonna watch
something on the television
uh the kids will be on their laptops
well vic's family is jewish
and so
um her
dad um likes to have the friday night
prayers
um and um uh so we do that occasionally
not religiously everything you're not
religious yourself no but we want our
children to understand his jewish
um you know family
uh they came from poland we want them to
raise the children
no we don't but we want them to know
um the rick's family is jewish and to
know the traditions and the history to
understand you know what is part of
their family obviously now
one final question i've really run out
of time and everyone's sorry to wind up
um
tony blair gordon-brown um actually he's
actually not gordon brown but tony blair
and kinnick they they did you sort of
have their families more in the public
eye and you said it's a conscious
decision not but
you know when people sort of talk about
who is kirsten with the person
isn't your family like your biggest
asset in a way
yeah and vic is fantastic and everybody
who's seen or met vic says you know
she's fantastic and she is fantastic
absolutely fantastic um but i don't want
you know we don't want our family
destroyed by all of this um of course
it's a difficult one to get right but
um you know i didn't we didn't have
children as sort of props in my
political life that's not why we had
kids we had kids because we wanted to
have a family of our own well kirsten i
should let you go because it's nearly
the weekend you've got to get home for
friday night thank you so much for
coming and talking to us on the show
today i appreciate it having me thank
you
and if you scan this qr code on your
screen now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show
stay with us because coming up next
reality tv star vicky patterson on her
dad and her own battle with alcohol
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
[Music]
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is
i'm not here to apologize i'm here to
fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these sofas and people's desks and
children's books and you can see inside
this home here people trying to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
or
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
welcome back each year tens of thousands
of people are treated for what the nhs
calls problematic drinking it's an issue
that tears families apart vicky
patterson's father's an alcoholic still
struggling with the disease and living
the last 10 years of her life in the
public eye she's also known for drinking
excessively she now has a new
documentary out vicki patterson my dad
alcohol and me
vicki thanks for joining us on the show
today now first of all you're a very
well known face to many people you've
been in a number of reality tv shows
including geordie shore where you
started that's sort of where it all
began for you and then of course she won
i'm a celebrity get me out of here
and i wanted to start off with this you
were a normal girl growing up in
newcastle
turned into this mega uh reality tv
style was it by accident or design did
is it what you wanted to happen in your
life or just did it happen to you that
was some introduction that might be
thank you very much
um so
i don't think i ever necessarily wanted
to be
famous like i wasn't a huge
like driving force behind the things i
did i think more than anything i wanted
to be successful
i always have wanted to be
like to do well at whatever i'm doing i
don't love predictability
and i suppose something about
this world i'm in now always appealed to
us and i don't know if it was the fame
it's probably more the money if i'm
honest
well you have become very successful at
what you're doing and i want to get onto
the documentary which is out this month
and i have to say
uh it made me cry
it was very moving i found it a very
moving documentary we could get onto
that in a minute but first i just want
to ask you about uh your time on geordie
shore you said uh it made you into
someone else
when you did it what what do you mean by
that vicky
i think when i first went on geordie
shore i was really young so i was about
21 22 and even though i felt so grown up
and you know like i knew it all which
you do at that age i was woefully
unprepared for what i was letting myself
in for and i definitely didn't have the
skills to navigate the space i found
myself in
i think even before i went on the show
i had issues with alcohol
and based on what i've learned from the
documentary i've definitely discovered
my motivations for drinking sort of all
stem
well drinking to excess anyway from when
i feel out of control
when i feel anxious
um in big social situations being in a
in a situation that i don't feel like i
have much control in which is a reality
tv show you know but also they encourage
it do they or did they at the time yeah
i think like you've jordy shaw
did it was exactly what it said on the
tin you know it was chaos and it was a
reality show that promoted
young girls and boys kissing
corridor creeping doing things they
probably shouldn't and probably like
drinking a bit too much i definitely
think it exacerbated the
the issues i've got with alcohol but it
certainly wasn't the start okay and
vicki before we get on to the
documentary what what what pulled you
out of geordie's sure what what made you
think
it's time i shouldn't be doing the same
what's not good for me what happened
i i got into a lot of trouble on my time
on geordie shore through being unhappy
out of control and losing all the things
i liked about myself
um and i think there was a
one particular pivotal moment where i
knew i needed a break
i was going through a lot personally and
i got told oh after the next series
you're definitely going to have a
prolonged break you can go on holiday
see your family see your friends do
whatever just have a relax
and then they put another series in they
took that breakaway
because it was becoming successful it
was gaining momentum and i get it
but
i told them i needed a break i said for
my mental health like i shouldn't really
be doing another series and that's
absolutely fine you can have a break but
you will replace you
and in that moment like i really
believed i was i was working towards
like making something like a huge show
with everybody and actually i just
realized i was very replaceable and
undervalued so that was the beginning of
the end for me
that must have been really hard wasn't
it you said i need a break and they said
fine but we'll replace you it was really
tough
i don't think there is many
there's a lot of more duty of care now
surrounding these shores and quite
rightly so
but back then i don't think we i think
we sort of were
guinea pigs in a way i know those people
who came before with the big brothers
and things like that but our particular
type of reality tv
we were everyone was learning as they
went
you do it again now
it's such a it's such a difficult
question to answer because obviously i'm
super grateful for where i am now
and i'm not arrogant enough to think i
would have got there
without the catalyst that was geordie
shaw
i love me platform i love all the
amazing things i get to do
and if it wasn't for geordie show i
wouldn't be here
but if i could have got here another way
i think i would have preferred that
well you did get here and then you went
on to when i'm a celebrity and i have to
i'll go and go but just
a couple of things about because i i
love watching that show
but i do wonder when i watch it is the
reality of it quite monotonous and
boring a lot of the time you've got no
phones no problems
it's honestly no food no booze that is
the hardest bits but everyone thinks
it's like the bugs and don't get me
wrong the heat is horrible especially
for like a little geordie like me and
you won i did i did that feel great
that was the best feeling ever it was
part of validation because nobody really
wanted us in there beforehand why not
i think everyone like if everyone had
this preconceived notion that i was this
like
angry sort of yob from geordie shore who
was gonna go in there and i don't know
punch a kangaroo or something like it
was absolutely ridiculous look let's get
on to the the documentary because that's
what you came on to talk about uh vicky
patterson my dad alcohol and me it says
it all in the title
it's a documentary about your dad uh
who's an alcoholic
the first thing i wanted to ask actually
was was how is your dad now at the
moment um so like i've often said like
the recovery from alcoholism it's not
linear there's always going to be
ups and downs
um and at the moment like my dad's doing
really well he's at my house as we speak
blessing but it was a little bit too hot
for him to get into london today
um but no he's doing well um
it's all we can hope for like every day
is a bit of a challenge but yeah he's
he's winning his battle at the moment so
that's that's really good to know
because the documentary is all about
his relationship with outcome your
relationship with him and his
difficulties his 30-year battle
trying to stop drinking and failing and
succeeding at different points
and you
explore that relationship with him in
it's an incredibly watchful and moving
documentary
um
the thing that comes out in it is that
this fear that you have that you are
going to become
your dad
always worried
because i'm like him in a lot of ways
you know and i
i was aware that i had an addictive
personality i do everything to extreme
extremes if i'm gonna go at the gym i'm
gonna go five days a week if i'm gonna
party i wanna be the last one standing
there's no there was never any balance
so i convinced myself
that it was a foregone conclusion that i
was just going to end up like my dad and
it led us down some real self-sabotaging
paths at times
and vikki you said you you talking the
documentary about having a complicated
relationship
with alcohol
do you think you're an alcoholic or
could become an alcoholic
or you think it's more nuanced for you
and it's about being mindful
i think um
i think there was
there was a period in my life where
there was a very good chance i could
have ended up being an alcoholic yeah
do you know what's the weirdest thing
when i came out of the jungle everyone
assumed like i had the world at my feet
and i should have been the happiest i've
ever been
but i was really out my death
and i had like raging imposter syndrome
like i didn't believe i deserved
anything i was getting and because i
felt out of place at these big parties
and i was meeting all these big celebs
that i didn't like i grew up watching
and i didn't think i deserved to meet i
drank to cope with being quite insecure
and overwhelmed
um and it could have easily gotten very
out of control
but my age and stepped in i got a
therapist i got help
um and i think that was a bit of a
turning point for me as well
but i i am aware that it's a very fine
line
between
sort of enjoying alcohol for me and not
being able to know when to stop and i
have to work really hard to be on the
right side of that lane so so did you
stop drinking for a while then after you
drank heavily after i'm and then did you
stop once you saw the therapist did you
think i've got to go cold turkey here or
was it never like that for you there's
been i've had periods of sobriety
definitely um more than anything to
prove to myself that i could
um
but no i've never been totally total and
i would like to avoid having to do that
if possible
and but i'm not opposed to it because
i'm sure you need to yeah definitely
there's other things i want more and
vicki that what what strikes me um in
the documentary is how close you are to
both your parents it's actually lovely
you can see that there is such a
connectivity between you and your mom
and also you and your dad and i wondered
watching it whether
after your mum and dad divorced
it seemed to me that you sort of had to
step in a bit and become
the kind of carer for your dad or take
responsibility in the family
for his alcoholism and trying to fix him
is that kind of what happened and
did you resent that or did you just
accept it as his daughter i wondered
whether it made you angry
this don't get us wrong there's been
times in my life where i've i've been
really angry at me dad for being an
alcoholic but i think that showed a lack
of understanding of the disease in
general and i'm sure anybody who is
going through something similar or has
in the past can understand it's an
incredibly frustrating disease
um
but he didn't choose to be this way
and i'm certainly no martyr
like me mum regardless of whether she
was married to me dad or living with him
or not she's always cared and she's
always been there and vicki i've got i
think we've got a clip actually from the
documentary when you're talking
uh to your mum about how you're feeling
i think can we play that
you know when i went on jordy shaw
never thought about what it must be like
for you having to watch me like abuse
alcohol and drink and become that
horrible version of myself
an echo so many
things my dad did i never thought about
that
i i didn't like seeing it
but i knew it wasn't you but i never
thought you were late in alcoholic like
i did your dad i thought she's just
young it's going to pass it's just when
she's in our 20s do you know what i mean
like i do work really hard you know yeah
to be
this version of me
i would love you to get the stage where
you don't have to work hard just be you
yeah oh
bless you i really love you i love you
too
[Music]
i love you mom she's lost isn't she yeah
she really is
she really is
is that hard
hearing your mom say that but also is it
getting easier for you do you think
um
i think i don't think i'll ever like
every time i watch the documentary i
still cry yeah it's
it's a hard watch it is a real teardrop
i for me and like it i can't remove
myself from it it's my life you know um
and again like me dad's recovery is it's
not all neatly sewn up we're still it's
ongoing so it'll always tug at me
heartstrings but
um no i think uh
i think i get emotional just because
my family means so much to us
and this documentary means a lot to us
as well you know like i'm i was dead
passionate about making it
i just wanted to ask you just about
your life now
because you're you know you're settled
you've got a lovely
boyfriend
you
you know you talk in the documentary
about wanting to get married and have
kids and
but you also talk about being scared
about having kids because you don't want
to repeat past patterns and also
obviously you can't drink for a number
of months really yeah i mean when i had
my babies it was a bit more relaxed you
could have a couple of drinks but i
think now the
recommendation is nothing isn't it
does that scare you that idea or
do you feel more ready now having gone
through the journey of the documentary i
think like years ago
i would have been really intimidated at
the prospect of going like nine ten
months even longer whatever it is
without a drink which is a really um
it's a horrible thing for us to admit
that doesn't make me proud you know i
also was just like really scared like
you say i was just gonna have children
who felt in some way broken
like me
um
but the documentaries brought us a lot
of peace and a lot of clarity
can i say you you do not seem like a
broken person
you really
you're actually the opposite i think
thank you
um
so sorry um
i felt like
and one of my main motivations for
making this documentary was that i had
this strong belief
that there was a huge element of
alcoholism that was completely genetic
that because my dad
had it in him i was just gonna have it
in me
and then i truly believed that my kids
would have it too
and i didn't want them to feel different
to everybody else to feel out of control
to feel powerless to stop something like
their life was only ever going obey one
way it was going to be hard and sad and
they were going to hurt people that
loved
so um
that's that was a huge reason why i
haven't had children yet
but now i am in a really good place with
a really nice man and i've done this
documentary and learned loads about this
illness
and i understand there's an element of
it that is learned behavior and
potentially hereditary
but more than that i know we have
choices as well yeah
okay well
thank you for coming on thank you thank
you for doing the documentary because i
think it will
help lots of people out there
who have
family members or our colleagues who
have lived through this in some way
um
and i really enjoyed talking to you so
thanks for coming on thank you so much
vicky patterson there with the issue
that affects so many families around the
country well stay with us because coming
up next the veteran dj judge jules on
the decks and the law
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
streaming has revolutionized the music
industry but for whose benefit artists
now struggle to earn the same living as
performers that made their fortunes from
cds and vinyl sales judge jules was once
hailed as the best dj in the world he's
also a music lawyer he thinks a good
grasp of the law is key for a prosperous
future in the industry
judge jules thanks for joining me on the
show today now you're known
as one of the world's biggest djs
i know you
from my youth
and watching you and listening to you
but for those people out there that
perhaps don't know you
they might be a bit younger than us
um can we start with why you're actually
called judge jules
i was i got into djing by promoting
events when i was 16 and
the the the best time to start promoting
really is when you're that young because
what you don't realize when you're 16 is
that's when you've got the biggest
social circle you're ever going to have
in your life and of course with each
passing five years your social circle
has and when you reach my age by this
point it's almost non-existent but the
good thing was i was putting on uh
events
at that age many of them were illegal
events and i should probably point out
that illegal then was a lot less illegal
than it now is because the laws were
subsequently tightened up yeah uh and
when we were promoting those illegal
events the police came to the door they
thrust innocent 18 year old dj jules to
the door to say
and i was a law student at the time uh
and uh
basically told the police this is for me
and my law student chums officer and
that from there came the name of the
judge i'm not a real judge i should have
hated to add but in my mind in my mind's
eye i am anyway
you became a uh
a lawyer
you did a law degree
but you were also a studious boy from
north london right you sort of had a
twin track life is that
fair to say i think i think there are
quite a lot of people in the music
business who do come out with a degree
and have a sort of educated background i
i don't think i was the only person in
that environment but we were part when i
was 16 to 21 we were part of a sort of
collective if you like that put on raves
that's what we did a couple of us were
at university a couple of us uh probably
came from families where nobody had ever
been in in any generation to university
but that was the kind of fun thing we
were just we were doing it for all the
right reasons because we absolutely love
what we did we love the music we were
supporting and they didn't and the music
we were supporting didn't really have
any outlet you lost your mum when you
were 18 years old that's incredibly
young to lose your your mum and i'm
sorry and i i lost my mum so i know how
rough it is did that
kind of change your outlook you know did
it did it kind of
change your view about how you wanted to
live your life or the risks you wanted
to take maybe i think i think i think it
had two i it had one um one impact that
i only realized quite a long time
afterwards which was
the the healing power of music
it's funny because when uh during the
pandemic i started doing live streams i
did probably about i've done about 100
live streams i'm still doing them
periodically now and whereas when you go
out and dj you might have a few beers
and you might sort of be a little bit
tipsy when you do a live stream you're
completely
stone cold sober and i was getting such
a buzz out of doing these live streams
and it was that that was my eureka
moment but wow music was what really
helped me through what was quite a
traumatic time in my life and then of
course the other thing i think you would
get the same answer out of anybody who
loses a parent early it makes you
realize it might all be gone tomorrow it
makes you realise the finality of life
and
it sort of kicks you into action
arguably faster than it would for others
who have a
slightly less sorry tale to tell at that
a similar age you are the first
generation of celebrity djs you were
voted the best dj in the world
let's just pause and enjoy that in 1995
by the dj mag what was it about the late
80s and 90s that gave rise to this
particular phenomena of the world famous
dj what was it about that time was it
quite a magical time it was a magical
time i mean it was
it's i i suppose what changed everything
and i don't want to sound like a luddite
because the internet or high-speed
internet
in many ways has has been the ultimate
um
propagator of all things artistic yeah
but before high-speed uh internet the
only way that you could discover this
incredible music this incredible vibe
was via a limited amount of touch points
which was kind of a handful of magazines
um record shops which specialist record
shops
a couple of shows on radio one and of
course these super clubs that existed in
many even quite small cities throughout
the uk
and i've always thought that the one
thing about clubbing stroke festival
culture is it's almost like the last
bastion of an opportunity to hang out
with people you don't know in a kind of
semi
for the most part a very safe
environment and jules the the the dance
music scene back then as we both know
was strongly associated to with hedonism
with partying of course with illegal
with illegal drugs
looking at you you are definitely not
one of those who are the casualty of
hard living may i say you're looking
very good
um was it unusual to stay removed from
all of that aspect of the lifestyle or
was it more common than maybe people
thought like you could be involved but
you didn't have to kind of partake in
the heavy drug taking yeah i think the
heart i think the hard party and
sometimes dare i say it is in the in the
people who hang around you know whether
they're djs or whether they're musicians
it's often the people who are hanging
around them rather than the artists
themselves because it's
the life yeah the life it's a job but
it's an it's a job that you're being
paid to do something that you would
willingly pay others to let you do but
at the same time it's a very hardcore
existence i was doing
two 200 250 shows a year probably 200
flights a year i still do not far shy of
that now but
going around the world doing a long haul
trip every every fortnight which sounds
like a on the one hand it's the dr you
know a schoolboy's dream on the other
hand you simply couldn't be absolutely
sort of uh
battered and bruised and do that it just
wouldn't work as it got more difficult
for musicians and artists to earn a
living because of
streaming and because of the way in
which the industry's changing it's got
more difficult to make a career for
yourself sticking your head above the
parapet is
has never been more difficult now there
are between sixty thousand and seventy
thousand spotify releases a day that's
nice um so you've gotta be an all-round
um
marketeer you've got a be business savvy
uh making good records just isn't enough
just on this ed sheeran was recently
awarded 900 000 pounds in legal for a
very high profile case after winning
that copyright talk in which he and two
of his co-writers were accused of
plagiarizing part of a song called a
white by a relatively unknown artist
sammy switch
where did your sympathies lie in that
case
it's very difficult because you i mean
one thing that you as a lawyer you need
to understand that a a copyright
infringement case has a has a lot of
different layers it has
expert opinion it has obviously what the
judges do
on the one hand there is a there is an
increasing culture of uh creatives um
screaming plagiarism uh both in
copyright and in other areas of
intellectual property yeah um and it's a
good thing if the bar is set a little
bit higher to prevent dare i say it's
sort of
lawyers working on no win no fee
on a no win no fee basis agreeing to act
on the behalf of people screaming blue
murder
on the other you do feel for you know
the little guy who's suddenly gonna
stump up a huge amount of legal fees do
you think that case was avoidable then
do you think that case shouldn't have
come to court
my my in my view no if if i listen to
the two the two songs
it's it's an ever moving feast and there
isn't really a right or wrong answer in
fact on the sky i commented a few times
um when that when that case was was
adjudicated but no in that particular
case no
let's just move on to politics um
a massive unforeseen challenge in face
by the industry
uh was the pandemic
and covid how how was that for you was
it really difficult covered was
difficult for me but much more difficult
for my peers because i've got this this
dual life my legal practice was very
strong
many of my peers fell through the cracks
because
a lot of people in the creative industry
were advised by their accountants to set
up your own small business and pay
yourself in dividends that was the the
stock accountant's advice to not just
musicians just about everybody now if
that's the way you paid yourself you got
zero support from the government right
and even though a lot of people were
crying out to rishi sunak to do
something about it he never did i want
to ask you about one of your former
colleagues dj tim westwood he's been
accused of sexual misconduct between
1992 and 2017. something which tim
westwood has denied this week the bbc
revealed it did receive complaints about
alleged sexual misconduct and bullying
by the dj one which was referred to the
police
when you saw those reports which you
know tim westwood did it surprise you
i wouldn't i i don't know tim wester
well enough to know whether any of it is
true or not but to to learn that the bbc
denied ever having received complaints
and now it has been discovered that
there were not just one but a number of
complaints is a really bad look for the
bbc a really bad look so i i don't feel
sort of qualified either legally or
morally to comment on what tim westwood
did because i simply don't know but it
but this does not reflect well on the
bbc that's for sure what do you think
the bbc have potentially been involved
in a cover-up
well with due to freedom of information
they're they're a public body for whom
freedom of information applies they were
never going to be able to cover it up it
seems
either very incompetent or a cover-up i
guess the question would be then given
that you weren't there
was there a sort of culture like that
during at the bbc during the time you
were there do you think or back in that
period of time did you witness that did
you ever pick that up no i would say
quite the opposite actually i thought
but then i was at the bbc immediately
after jimmy savile
well not after the jimmy savile stuff
happened but after it came out i was i
started on the bbc two a couple of years
later
and
that so if anything there was a really
proactive attempt to be inclusive to not
allow that to happen so it's
disappointing that um
the similar stories have occurred but
again i don't want to sort of cast
aspersions on what did or didn't happen
no what do you think the bbc should do
about it now
there's going to be serious internal
questions asked about how
it was said in the first instance
whenever it was a couple of months ago
that there had that nothing had occurred
when there is such a
when the proof of the pudding has been
discovered so soon afterwards um
something has gone very wrong how the
decision-making worked in the upper
echelons of the bbc i don't know but
questions i mean it sounds like a very
vague answer but questions certainly
need to be asked okay thank you very
much thanks for joining me i really
enjoyed that and
have fun in ibiza well that's all for
today's show and for this season we'll
be back in september with more famous
names amazing stories and a new prime
minister thank you to all of our guests
and thank you for watching i hope you've
enjoyed it as much as i have
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to beth
rigby interviews podcast and new
episodes available now each week i take
a look at the highlights of the
interviews and there's some extra bits
and pieces in there too that's on the
sky news app or wherever you get your
podcasts
and do stay with us coming up next it's
sky news at 10
[Music]